Và khoảng khúc dởi mối phút hôm nay, bể tạm tạm tạm 2 năm 2020, tại khúc vực đường dẫn vào trạm dự gì,
kêu mấy bụng mấy mốt, các tốc thình vô chiming lòng thành dấu dây, hướng lòng thành dấu dây,
thuộc điều phần xa xe quế, tình đồng này, sẽ ra vụ thành hạn dưới xe ô tốt thứ,
chưa gió bình dấu xó bị trái dụi hoàn toàn, đâm vào đôi xe ô tốt đầu kéo bình dấu 3,5 hát không 2 một bốn 2 kéo thơ dự gì dơ mốt.
Rồi lại xe viễn vàng quan, xin năm 2020, chú hước sân, hà tính, đường khiến đo dấu xe tại gió đường đi vào trạm dự gì.
Chia xe kêu thương có năm người sau vào trạm xe ô tốt thứ đặc bốc trái,
hành người đã thân ra được băng người còn lại từ vòng.
Nhìn định xe bộ viên bản đầu, rồi lại xe ô tốt thứ thương đường khiến xe không chú ý quả sát,
chế nhé không giám tốc độ khi đã vào để khu vực trạm dự gì và thế xe đo kéo dừng đối phía trước,
dẫn đến tên an xa thông, xe đo kéo dừng đối phía quý định, dừng giấu xe đo đường có bình báo cấm dừng đối phía,
muy nhiên của vụ tên an đăng được công an tình đồng này sắp mình làm só theo quý định của pháp lật.